look man i just think is there is there
anyone you would trust to regulate
twitter and youtube and facebook like
who would you who would do it oh that's
a good question i don't think it should
be one person either i think it's also
like president like being president i
don't think she should be the president
of twitter that's i really think it
might be wise for all of us to consider
it like a public utility
you would socialize twitter yeah i'd
give it to bernie
that's incredible
and this is where we find ourselves with
elon musk about to buy twitter yeah i
saw that apparently it's going down it
happened oh [ __ ]
what oh [ __ ]
the press release has been announced
elon musk just bought twitter we got a
movie star
type of a superhero electric cars
insane elon musk agrees to buy twitter
in a 44 billion dollar deal apparently
it was really close yesterday and i had
heard um this morning that it was
probably going to happen but the fact
that it's now announced that's [ __ ]
amazing